i don't know if people know this but  pippin in the party scene  is playing  the uh mandolin in the band  that's right when uh on stage when sam  sees um rosie cotton and stuff  uh it was a nice little thing with the  writers it was philip a boy and so said  you actually play don't you and i said  yeah and they said why don't you go up  and join the band then oh great so let's  see  no no i'm a mandarin a mandolin mandolin  little spanish cakes where's the thing  where you can cut your fingers off  accidentally uh hunting knife no  you're cutting a now pointy very thin  slices oh julianne julian yeah if you're  cutting it julienne the thing that you  cut it on i think that's called the  mandolin as well is it i think so  brilliant  harmonize with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your boy's the baby you're my pearl